Last weekend, Music
and Theater Arts
had a series of events
that were happening.
They put up a live
stream online.
When a friend told me our
video had 14,000 views,
I was like, blown away.
Puts pressure on in a good
way to know that there
are that many people watching.
Does have implicit feel of
being a much larger arena.
It was like, oh, greetings from
Rome, greetings from Brazil.
I think it was great to show
people that MIT wasn't limited
to just technology.
We're doing arts
plus technology.
My parents got to
watch it, which
was really awesome, because
they live in California.
So it's not really feasible
for them to fly all the way out
here.
And so they were
very, very happy
and sent me lots of
texts at the end.
Most of the students
who come to MIT--
they have a
performance background.
I did not expect this
is as a high school
student coming to like a
science and math school.
I kind of felt like I was almost
making a sacrifice of music
to come here.
And so finding out that there's
so much support and energy
and money that goes into this
is really, really wonderful.
It's pretty sublime,
I guess you could say.